why would you ever go back to an office
space when you could do everything on
zoom and
because i think like we're social
animals like people want to be around
that they want to go back to work they
don't want the coffee shop to close down
so i think it's going to come back i do
look like look at depression gun
violence
it's going to come back domestic
violence through the [ __ ] roof it's
gonna come out
people need each other yeah i say do we
even have a um
what do you need mask in here is there
like a give a one of those doctory
looking ones
why what do you want to do what do you
want yeah i'll take it let me see that
[ __ ]
all right boy towards that [ __ ] right
now hell yeah dude torture all right
give me that one yeah we want to ruin
one do it dude
but don't you think like those days like
he can kind of come back when all the
all the boys get together like you being
here yeah you know and like you get
santino bobby
[ __ ] is over he's blame it dude dude i'm
in [ __ ] all different cities brothers
nobody's wearing these [ __ ] in
l.a anymore nobody dude nobody's wearing
these anywhere bro so this is the end of
this
this is the end of this dude anyway yeah
we are
oh yeah yeah dude well no they are the
only place they're wearing it is la
yeah but they're not even really wearing
it even here little by people are doing
it just to judge others
yeah yeah that's what it is yeah [ __ ]
that dude i'm i'm i'm kind of done with
it
you go i was in miami poppy open oh
whoa open there's not a mask in sight
they made fun of me
shows were full capacity right correct
100 like it was 2019 like there was no
pandemic
and you were performing to a full crowd
no masks no matter so you felt like you
went back in time correct that's dope
and then you walk outside and there's a
nightclub right outside there just every
columbia with a giant ass packed
wall-to-wall dicks to butts bro
did you go in you guys go into some bars
you have some fun huh go out yeah
dude why don't colombian guys down there
oh look i'll tell you this i met some
mexican guys the other day and they said
they don't
have the disease in mexico interesting
that's fair
there's a lot of them dying in mexico so
who knows what that is could be cartel
violence but here you go
yeah spring break state of emergency
also florida just today said governor
desantis said they have the lowest rate
of cases
in the last six months they have the
lowest rate so i'm and i'm i'm sorry the
governor of texas rick abbott
said they have the texas which has had
no mass for a month has got the lowest
rate of coverage
they have a mandate where you can't what
you can't uh force people to wear masks
even in businesses
right who's a mandate it sounds like
some girl or one of our friends
posted yeah but you can't but yeah but
if you want to wear the map
i'm all about just giving people options
dude asian's been wearing masks forever
yeah that's yeah
what's happening now black people are
beating them up exactly as soon as as
soon as they show their face where did
that get you
yeah yeah i know dude that's the best
thing that could have happened first so
you you two have known each other
a black guy committed that crime if that
would have been another white it would
have been
overdue over but thank you thank god it
was a black person
dude thank god it's black thank god it's
black dude shout out black people man
yeah love them
is